[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 برنامج
في ايران النظام يستنجدوا بالاصلاحين
وبوسائل قمع ان الجديده شرطه الاخلاق بلا
اخلاق ومكبر التحقيقات يظهر
التكنولوجيا تعيد رسم العالم من الانترنت
الاشياء الى الحروب ابتكارات من غير
تقليديه عسكريا برداء مدني
وفي ملفات الساعه الستون مكاسب اوكرانيا
تفتح اعينها على القرم حاله
هلا اطلق الون ماسك النار على قدميه تويتر
يهتز بين مماس يغيروا الالوان ذهبي ورمودي
وازرق
[موسيقى]
الاساليب القديمه وعقليه الحصانه لدى من
يمارسون السلطه ببساطه لا تنجح نحن امام
ازمه حقوق الانسان متكامله وبهذه الكلمات
باتت هناك لجنه امميه لتخصي الحقائق
وهدفها توثيق انتهاكات حقوق الانسان وقمع
السلطات الايرانيه للمتظاهرين الذين لم
يتخلوا عن الشارع لا ملاذ لهم اليه
الانترنت مقطوع لكن الصوت مسموع وصداه قد
وصل بحسب العفو الدوليه لكن الازمه ان لكل
صوتا يسمع هناك ثمن وللاسف يدفعه
الايرانيون اعتقاله حوالي اربعه عشر الف
شخص ولم يسلم الاطفال من الامر ايضا قاموا
عنا همجي بتعبير مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيكسالبان الحراك هو الاحتجاجيه
لا يقتصر لا على طبقه ولا على جغرافيا
محدده تحركات الطبقه الوسطى والفقيره في
المقدمه والمحركه اقتصادي السياسي وثقافيه
صحيفه اعتماد تتحدث بناء على تحليل مقاطع
فيديو وهذه المقاطع اظهرت ان طهران والمدن
الكرديه كانت اكبر بؤر للاحتجاجات خلالها
اول شهر
استخدمت الرصاصه الحي والمطاطيه ضد
المتظاهرين بالاضافه لوسائل قمع اخرى وفقا
لتقارير موثقه تقدر حاصله الوفيات باكثر
من 300 شخص حتى لحظه بينهم اربعون طفل على
الاقل وهذا امر غير مقبول تلقينا تقارير
تفيد بان الجرح في المظاهرات يخشون الذهاب
الى المستشفيات حتى لا يتم اعتقالهم
التوام الط تحدثت عن تدخلات من قبل قوات
الامن اثناء علاجهم للجرحى مما تم جمعه من
تقارير هناك نحو 14000 شخصا معتقلين لدى
السلطات بما فيهم اطفال
الاحتجاجات هو في كل انحاء البلاد ولهذا
فارقم المعتقلين كبيره الانتفاضه ارضه
النظام
تعكسه اوراق مبعثره غير منظمه تبدو في
حاله فوضى امام مكبر التحقيق الاممي تماما
كما تعاني السلطات
اذن الموده
وثابته السلطات تحاول ابتكار لكن ليس من
اجل الحل وانما للقمر سيارات الاسعاف احدى
الوسائل تستغلها للتسلل للتظاهرات من اجل
نقل المصابين ثم يحدث ما تريده الاعتقال
الاعداد تتزايد تحقيق النيويورك تايمز احد
الشهود العيان قال انه راى ما لا يقل عن
ثلاثه متظاهرين ايه يتم الزنج بهم في
سياره اسعاف خلال مظاهره طلابيه لكن
المتظاهرين لم يكونوا مصابين من الاساس
شاهدا اخر الصحيفه التايمز البريطانيه
حللت وحددت المواقع الجغرافيه لمقاطع
الفيديو السيارات الاسعاف هذه تدخل وتخرج
من مراكز الشرطه او يتم وضعها خارجها
مباشره وربما تفيد هذه المعلومات جهه
التحقق الامني
[موسيقى]
فعلوا اضراب النار اضراب النار كما شاهدنا
بصور وتماثيل رموز النظام بحد ذاته ليست
فعلا جديده على المتظاهرين لكن هناك احراق
اخر له خصوصيه ومعنى الاكبر
هذا بيت الخميني مؤسس النظام الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الايرانيه التغير وصل الى ورثته
ابنائه رفضوا مطالبات النظام بمحاولتي
اخماد الاحتجاجات والعهده على السجن احراق
بيت الخميني كما شاهدنا هو رساله ودليل
على تغير اخر الشارع من الصعب اتصور ان
شخصا اضيفت اليه هاله القدس ونزع عنهما هو
انساني واصبغه عليه الصفه الخارق العقلاني
ان ذلك البيت ذلك البيت كاي بيت صنع شخصيه
الخميني وشكلها لكن الصوره التي رسمت عن
الخميني تحرره من مساوته مع غيره احراق
البيت احرق تلك الاسطوره الفعل وان بدا
عني فان فهو ينزع عنه الهال ويؤنسنه
بالاحرف يصدر عليه حكم الموت حقا على
تركته الايديولوجيه تحديدا ويمنع تخليده
وبجعله
يمكن القول الان ان اسرار الشعب وصل
لمرحله اللا عوده جذوره النظام يتم
اقتلاعها من حوزات قم وهنا لحظه كسر
المحرمات ترست ولا احد يعلم متى واين
تتوقف النظام نفسه يحاول
التغير حدث كما ذكرنا لكن لنظام فقط ولا
الانتفاضه خمدات غير ان شيئا ما تغير وائل
الابد الشتاء القادم ينبئ بعواصف لن تمر
بهدوء المجتمع والتحمى واتحد بشكل غير
مسبوق وهناك عفويه وصدق للاحتجاجات وربما
هي السبب والدليل فيما يجري في اقصى
الشمال يسمع صدى في اقصى الجنوب حتى
الفئات الاكثر تشددا والقريبه من النظام
وليس الاصلاحيون فقط ان حازت للانتفاضه
فلم تبقى عائله
هو قتل لها ابن او ابن في الاسابيع
والسنوات الاخيره وهذا ما يقوله المؤرخ
ستيفان ضد يونان ام مؤلف كتاب حراس الثوره
الاسلاميه وكتاب علم الاجتماع السياسي
لمليشيا الدوله
اعتمدت على مداهمات قوات الامن لاكثر
الاحياء تدينا كحي نرماك الذي يقع شرق
العاصمه طهران ولا يبدو ان جرح الشعب
سيلتئم قريبا بل سيستمر وليجيال وسيبقى هم
اسقاط النظام مرتبط بكل الالام هما مشتركا
للشعب الايراني بقوميته المختلفه
اخطاؤه النظام كثرت والمعالجه تاخرت رئيس
مستعد للاستماع للمطالب كما قال لكن الثقه
فيه عدم تقريبا الشعب بجميع اطيافه وفئاته
يتمرد وابطال الرياضه من المتصدرين المشهد
واليكم بعض وتاني في فريق السنوكر
تستقيلان
شريف ايران خليفه
اخر من اعضاء فريق الكاراتيه في المانيا
وقفنا بدون حجاب وبرساله تضامنا واضحه
المراه الحياه الحريه وهنا ايضا لاعبوا
منتخب كره القدم صمتهم اهز الملعب في قطر
واغضب السلطات في ايران الجمهور صفر فوق
نغمات النشيد لتبقى الوحده وتنسى وافتراض
سوء النيه هو السائد لكل ما يتعلق بقرارات
النظام من قولا وفعل وهذا الشك انتقل الى
قلب السلطه ولم تعد مبادرات امتصاص الغضب
تؤتي اكلها عن نظام طلب وسلطه المعتدلين
وربما تاخر كثيرا واهلاله لمناطق وتميزه
لطائفه واعراضه عن الحوار خلق رغبه موحده
للاطاحه به
ادوات القمع النظام تخصص حتى سيارات
الاسعاف التي تحدثنا عنها قبل قليل ويبدو
ان المرشد لا يتردد في فعل اي شيء لاسكات
المعارضين وهكذا ترى واشنطن التظاهرات في
ايران لا يمكن تبريره استخدام العنف
المفرد ضد المتظاهرين وان حصلت نادم
بالتخريب في احيانا سلامه الشعب اهم من
سلامه الممتلكات العامه الامن منفذ والامر
والامر هو المرشد وتعزيز الفضيله مبدا
الراسخ في الجمهوريه الاسلاميه ولهذا
انشئت وحده شرطه الاخلاق ومهمتها فرض
قوانين اللباس الاسلاميه على النساء
والفتيات في الاماكن العامه لكن ما يدور
خلف الابواب عكس كلمه هو اخلاقيه شبكه
روسيه ان حققت ولي شهرين ورود القصه التي
تدور خلف قضبان السجون الايرانيه والقصه
تبدا من هذه النقطه تحديدا من معبر الحاج
عمران بيقسم المنطقه ويقسم المنطقه ذات
اغلبيه كرديه تمتد من غرب ايران الى شمالي
العراق وبعد الاحتجاجات خفت حركه عبور
العائلات الكرديه عبر الممر الحاجز تحول
الى مصيده للهاربين من القمع لكن حاجه
العبور لكردستان زادت لتصبح الجبال العراق
هي السبيل فطريق الموت كان اهون من مراكز
الاحتجاج للنظام وذلك بشهاده المعتقل
السابقه هانا لمده 24 ساعه عاشت هنا ومعها
40 امراه وعشارات الاطفال لحظات رعب
ووحشيه لا توصف تفاصيل المكان هذا هي
الاقرب لما تمكنت هانا من ان تتذكره هنا
في حي اسلام اباد في اورميه كانت الفتيات
ينقلنا من القاعه الرئيسيه الى احدى غرف
الاستجواب ويتم والاعتداء عليهم حسن الحبر
خرجت هنا بكفاله من والدها لكن الاخريات
يعشنا مصيرا مجهولا يحيط به الرعب في كل
لحظه
العنف الجنسي هو الوسيله الجديده للقمع
رغم النفي السلطات للطبع لكن في زمن وسائل
التواصل حبل النفي او الكذب الاحرار لا
تقصيرا قصيرا جدا هذه الفتاه انثى عباسي
لم تتجاوز 20 عاما باتت مهساين الجديده
اعتقلت امريكا في السابع عشر من اكتوبر
الماضي اي بعد اسبوعين على احتجامها صدر
بيان اي يبرر اعتقالها النظام قرر انها
زعيمه الشغب لكن المعروف مع السلطات طيران
ان هناك دائما روايه اخرى حقيقه
حقيقه ما حصل مع عباسي كشفها 94 اشرفوا
على علاجها وتروي تسريبات كيف تعرضت
امريكا لاغتصاب الوحشي وهي في مركز
الاحتجاز اي بعد اعتقالها وبعد انتقادها
السلطات على تيك توك الادهى ان عملاء
النظام وفقا للشهادات يقومون بتصوير مشاهد
الاعتداء الجنسي وهذه هذه المشاهد اي
يحولونها لاداه ابتزازا ضد المتظاهرين
يضمنون بها سقوط ضحاياهم ويضغطون عليهم
لتسهيل اعتذار للحكومه كل هذا كان في
الخفاء حتى كشفته التقارير الاعلاميه
العالم ادان وتوعد ابي عقوبات لكن
المفارقه ان امريكا وبعد ما كانت زعيمه
الشغب باتت مريضه بالجهاز الهضمي هكذا غير
النظام روايه يقال انه كي تستطيع اخفاء
كذبه ستضطر للكذب الف مره
فما معنى نظام ايران سيحدث الامر ويتكرر
امراتان
محتجزتان اتعرضتا للتهديد باغتصاب اخوتهما
المراهقات كوسيله للضغط عليهن للادلاء
باعترافات تلفزيونيه قصريه هذه المره
الشهاده هنا للطفل يبلغ من العمر 17 عاما
قال انه واصدقائه تعرضوا للاغتصاب والساق
بالكهرباء في الحج بعد اعتقالهم في
الاحتجاجات ويبقى السؤال الى متى يستمر
واكذب السلطان وهل تشفع مسرحيه فتح
تحقيقات بشان الاعتداءات على المتظاهرين
للنظام الايراني ام لا
اساطير
[موسيقى]
ولمتابعه هذا الملف ينضم الينا عبر سكايب
اندرو بيك النائب الاسبق لمساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه لشؤون ايران اهلا بك
هناك عقوبات فرضات وهناك مواقف او واضحه
غربيه اخرها كان من الخارجيه الفرنسيه
للتمديد بهذا العنف الممارسه على على
المتظاهرين لكن برايك ما الذي يمكن ان يضع
حظا للنظام بعد المعاني في هذه الانتهاكات
بحق المتظاهرين وخاصه بعد ان وصلت الى
الاغتصاب
و الله
مفيدان
اولهما هو استهداف ضباط الشرطه الذين
قاموا بهذا العنف وهذا اعني فيه
استهدافهم بالعقوبات هذا لن يؤثر على
المليشيا والبسيج في الشارع
[موسيقى]
العصي ويضربون الناس
فلن يتاثر
اما الامر الثاني فهو
النتائج الاقتصاديه على النظام الذي يحتاج
الى تدفق
العملات الصعبه كالدولار واليان
وبالتالي لا بدرى من التسبب
بتراجع عملتهم
وايضا تصدير النفط الى الصين
البراميل يوميا
انت مكنا منهما اعتقد ان النظام عندها
سيختار طريق الحوار وليس طريق القمر نعم
هناك عقوبات وايضا هناك عقوبات ثانويه على
الشركات التي تساعد في تصدير النفط
الايراني ولكن هناك ايضا خطوه اتخذتها
ايران وهي قرار رفع التخصيب في فوردو الى
60% ينبر اليها على محاوله على انها
محاوله لدفع الاحتجاجات الى المرتبه
الثانيه في الاهتمام الدولي ام هي هل يا
فعلا محاوله من قبل ايران لتصعيد نووي
وايضا هي رد على ضغوط الوكاله وكاله
الطاقه الذريه
تحكم بشكل صحيح انه كان هناك
علمهم يتخلون
[موسيقى]
ان قلقهم
المتظاهرين
وبجهد للحصول على اتفاق النوويه هذا هو
المثل الايراني واعتقد انهم يحقون في ظلهم
على الجانب الاخر الولايات المتحده اليوم
بحسب نيويورك تايم سيتحدثت عن محاكاه
امريكيه لضرب منشات فوردو يعني هذا تحول
كبير في المقاربه الامريكيه اليس كذلك
العراق او سوريا في 2007
لا اعتقد ان هناك حماس كبير او قدره من
الجانب الامريكي للقيام بمثل بضربه عسكريه
فلا ارى ان هذا امر مستقيم ولا اعتقد ان
الايرانيين ايضا يعتقد لنا ذلك ربما يكون
ضمن الخيرات التي دائما
علاقاتنا الشائكه ماذا بين العملات
الرقميه حرب اوكرانيا والحزب الديمقراطيه
في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
كيف يغني بانسجام المثلي هكذا كان
كاريكاتير صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه
المرشد الرئيس رئيسي رئيس القضاء
صيانه الدستور الجنه
منتخب كره القدم الذي رفض ترديد نشيد في
مباراه
انجلترا تضامن مع الاحتجاجات يعلمه ماذا
الانسجام لكن كيف الطريقه في وسائل القمع
المختلفه المنتخب الايراني
الفتاه الايرانيه تمسك اليوم بقميص بلادها
في مباراته امام ويلز الدموع وكانها دماء
الرقم 22 لكن الاسم الاسم
الاضواء في البيت لم يعد بحاجه الى من
يضغط على الزر بل حتى الى من يوجد في داخل
البيت الفضل في ذلك يعود للانترنت الاشياء
الذي رافق الجيل الرابع من الانترنت اما
الجيل الخامس
فسينقلنا ببساطه الى مستوى اخر اجراء
العمليات الجراحيه مثلا عن بعد شبكه
الانترنت
مثل العديد من التقنيات الحديثه ولدت في
مخابر التقنيات العسكريه قبل ان تعمم ابعد
عقودا على المجالات المدنيه الحال تغير
اليوم الجيوش باثت تتعلم من التكنولوجيا
المدنيه التي فاقت فاعليتها ثرى سنه
الجيوش الاكثر تقدما بل هو باقل التكاليف
وشواهد على ذلك كثيره مشاهدينا مايكروسوفت
دعمت الامن السيبراني لهم ماسك قدم محطات
انترنت اوكرانيا عبر الاقمار الصناعيه
التكنولوجيا سمحا بوصولها الى مخترعين
الشباب حتى في الدول الفقيره لكن للقصه
جانب سلبي وايضا تقنيات حديثه وقعت في يد
الارهابيين من الشاب الحوثي في اليمن مثلا
استخدمت الطابعات الثلاثيه الابعاد لصنع
اجزاء من مسيراتها اوكرانيا حاولت اراضيها
قبل الحرب مقرا للعديد من شركات الذكاء
الصناعي الناشئه استخدمت الشبكه نفسها
لتطويل نوع جديد من التقنيات المهجنه
الطبعات الثلاثيه الابعاد استخدمت لصنع
ذيلنا يركب على القنابل اليدويه البسيطه
والتجربه جعلت من مسيرات تباع على انها
العابه هو الى اهداف الفتاكه دمرت معدات
بالملايين
اطلقت الحرب المستمره في اوكرانيا العنانه
لبعض الابتكارات غير التقليديه في المجال
العسكري والاستثمار في الابتكارات غير
العاديه في التكنولوجيا العسكريه يمكن ان
يتراوح بين الشركات العملاقه مثل لوكد
مارتن او ريسون او من المؤسسات التي
تمولها الحكومه مثل وكاله مشاريع الابحاث
الدفاعيه الامريكيه المتقدمه داربه
الجزيره بالملاحظه هو دور شركات
التكنولوجيا الشابه التي شبهت بالاطفال
الصغار في الساحه الابتكار الطائرات بدون
طيار هي مثال على ذلك فالشركات الاصغر مثل
دبرون الامريكيه وانظمه جيرمن
هي بؤره الابتكار السريع الاوكرانيون اذهل
المراقبين العسكريين بالخطوات الجريئه
التي اتخذوها خاصه في المعارك البحريه حين
ارسل سبعه طائرات بحريه وتسعين مسيرات
تتميز بنظام دفع من ماركه جاسكي كنديه
شهيره الامر الذي يعطي فكره عن مستقبل
هروب البحريه والتكنولوجيا العسكريه ذات
الاستخدام المزدوج
ما هو التكنولوجيا الهجينه في الحروب
الكلاسيكيه باتا نسقه متسارعا لكن النتائج
ليست دائما مضمونه وسيارته بيرقدار
التركيه مثلا ورغم تحقيقها لنتائج جيده في
ارمينيا وافريقيا لم تحقق المراد امام
بلدا يمتلك دفاعاتن جويه منظمه مثل روسيا
هذا التعثر للمسيرات جعل المواجهه تنتقل
من الجو الى البحر والمثال هو الاستهداف
الاخير للقوات الاوكرانيه لبناء
روسيا ولي اول مره في تاريخ المعارك يحدث
هجوم بقوارب مسيره على اسطول انا بحري 700
كيلو متر قطعتها القوارب المسيره من بناء
قدسه
لكن كيف الاسطوره بحجم الاسطول الروسي لا
يكتشف هذه القوالب المسيره والاجابه في
الارتفاع الصغير للقارئ الذي يجعله يبحر
دون كشفه قبل الرادارات مع امكانيه ان
يحمل الذخيره يصل وزنها الى 200 كيلو جرام
او بماذا يبلغ 800 كم وهكذا حللت البحريه
الروسيه الامر لكن بعد فوات الاوانب
التكنولوجيا المدنيه كانت الاساس محرك
القوارب صمم اساسا لتشغيل الجالسكي او
الثلاجات المائيه صنع في كندا عبر شركه
اسيدو لكن ثمه امر مميز اخر على سطح
القوارب المسيره الهوائي والذي يسمح
بانتقاطي الانترنت عبر اقمار ستار لينك
وهو ما يوفر فرصنا لتحديد الهدف بدقه نجاح
القوارب المسيره في عمليه بحجم استهداف
ميناء نيفرسوس سيكس جعل كيابه تطالب
بالتبرعات من اجل تصنيعه مماثله القطعه
الواحده منه تتطلب 250 الف دولار
رانيا تطلب التبرعات من اجل القوارب نعم
لكنها تطلب التبرعات في العموم للمساعده
في الحرب امر يظهر لنا جانبا اخر من
التكنولوجيا الهجينه البيتكوين تحول الى
رصاصنا وقودا وسطره واقيه واوكرانيا شكرت
مجتمع العملات المشفره على المساعده شركه
اف تي اكس التي كما نعلم اعلنت افلاسها
كانت حاضره منذ مارس مع الحكومه
الاوكرانيه وهذا امر معلن تبرعاتا لكيف
بالعملات المشفره المنصه التي تم اطلاقها
جامعه بالفعل 60 مليون دولار لدعمني
اوكرانيا بحلول مايا وكان قد صنفانه 54
مليون للحصول على المعدات الحربيه وهناك
فجوه باكثر من خمسه ملايين سنتحدث عنها
لاحقا مشاهدينا لكن هناك امر اخر جاء على
الشهور بجانبي كل ما اثير حول
اجعلها تتزايد واخيرا قيام حدثت منصه جمع
التبرعات قبل ثلاثه ايام من اعلان بنك مان
افلاسه حكومه زينسكي فتحت منصه اخرى دون
اي اشاره لافت اكس وهنا ظهرت حرب اخرى ليس
في اوكرانيا وانما في الولايات المتحده
بنكمان اف تي اكس متهمني بغسل اموال
المساعدات الامريكيه لاوكرانيا ولصالح من
لصالح الديمقراطيين ابي حسب الاتهامات
الاموال التي دفعها بايضا تعود لها كيف
المساعدات في اوكرانيا تستخدمها الاخيره
في اكس ثم يتم التبرع بها لتمويل الحزب
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه لا دلائل كثيره حتى
الان سوى الفجوه التي ذكرناها قبل قليل
خمسه ملايين و500,000 دولار ما بين المقدم
والمصروف لكن التقرير التي تشير الى ذلك
تستند الى عده الشواهد
اولا بنكمان اسس شركه اف تي اكس في ابريل
2019 نفس الشهر الذي اعلن فيه بيضا الترشح
للرئاسه ثانيا في اطار حملته بانك مان منح
اكثر من خمسه ملايين للمجموعات التي تدعم
بايظن ومنها حمله تلفزيونيه مدتها 11 ساعه
تستهدف الولايات المتاحه لجعل العمله
المشفره ثاني اكبر منيحا الي بعدا ثالثا
في عام 2022 العام الحالي ان فقط ما
يقربوا من 40 مليون دولار على المرشحين
الديمقراطيين والحملات ولجان العمل
السياسي ورابعا اعلنت اف تي اكس ال
الافلاس بعد الانتخابات النصفيه دليل
واربعه شواهد لكن ماذا يقول البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
لكن ان كانت الحرب هديه لواشنطن بحسب مركز
تحليل السياسه الاوروبيه حيث يمكنها من
توفير المليارات بالمقارنه بمكانه ستنفقه
على ردع روسيا لكن هذه الحرب هي ماساه
لاوكرانيا حربا بدات في القرم قبل تسع
سنوات وستنتهي بها بحسب زنسكي القرمه كانت
منصه عمليات روسيه عسكريه فهل لا تكون
الحرب النقمه ايضا على روسيا بينما اولويه
كل اهدافها في اوكرانيا حسبما صرح بوت
اليوم فاولويتك حاليا استعادته الشبه
جزيره القرم واملها في ذلك يستند الى
التراجع الروسي مؤخرا وتحديدا الانسحاب من
خرسانه
سيطره الاوكرانيين على خرسون تضعوا شبه
جزيره القرم قابقه قوسين من نيران
المدفعيه الاوكرانيه لا سيما انظمه هاي
مارس وناس ماس فبعد استعاده خرسون اضطر
للجيش الروسي الى ابعاد مهابط الطائرات
المروحيه والطائرات دون طيار والاليات
والمعدات الثقيله من المنطقه كما زاد ذلك
من حماس الاوكرانيين لاستعاده كامل لاراضي
المقاطعه التي تفصل شبه الجزيره عن مناطق
سيطره الروس وقطع الامدادات عنها من
المناطق الانفصاليه وجعلها شبه محاصره الا
من جسر القرم في الوقت الذي يدعو الرئيس
الاوكراني حلفائه الغربيين على دعم قوته
التي تحقق تقدما كبيرا بسرعه المطلوبه حتى
لا تتسنى الفرصه للروس لالتقاط انفسهم
ويصف دعوات التفاوض بمحاولاته لكسب الوقت
والاستعداد لمزيد من الاعمال العدائيه
ولاجل تحقيق هذا الامل لا فالقرمو هدف
الرئيسي للنار الاوكرانيه او بالاحرى
المسيرات وتحديدا سبيستون عاصمتها ومركز
اسطول البحر الاسود خرج رئيس مكتب زلسكي
اندريه
لامر بالغ الاهميه عمليه عسكريه محتمله
مطالبه الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا
بالواقعيه وهنا يطرح السؤال هل تستطيع
اكرانيا تنفيذ ذلك بمساعده الغربيه من
وجهه نظر رئيسي لجنه الدفاع والامن في
البرلمان الروسيه
كيف لا تملكو الموارد اول القوه اللازمه
اخيرا نقطه اتفاقنا روسيا امريكي
عايزين
كيف تتعامل معه
البحر الاسود
فهو اخيرا التعزيزات ان نشرت في الوقت بين
الحادي عشر والخامس عشر من الشهر الجاري
وفي محيط الميناء لجات روسيا لواحده من
اهداف الغواصات في العالم غواصه كيلو
المحسنه هي النسخه المحصله التي تتميز
بتكنولوجيا التخفي مع نطاق قتاليا ممتده
لضرب الاهداف الارضيه والصحيه وتحت الماء
كما لجات موسكو لسفن دوريا من فئه بروجيكت
220 تتضمن مهامها الراصده وحمايه السفن
اثناء العبور في المنطقه الاقتصاديه
الخالصه والمياه الاقليميه لروسيا وكانت
هذه محمد طراد مصطفى الذي تلقت فيه روسيا
الضربه الاكبر في هذه الحرب
ومنك ينضم الينا لمناقشه هذا الملف عبر
سكايب يوري سات مستشار وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني اهلا بك اذا الو المتحده تطلب
عدم الواقعيه من اوكرانيا بما يتعلق
باستعاده القرم هل تلتقط كياب الاشاره
ربما على عدم استعداد الغرب وتحديدا
الولايات المتحده في مساعدتها على تحقيق
هذا الهدف
مساء
الاوكرانيه
ومنذ 2014 عندما
تم ضم همم بشكل غير شرعي للاراضي همم
الاراضي القرم همم لروسيا قلنا دوما انها
ستعود الى اوكرانيا ويوم امس عندما قال
رئيسنا
سيدزلن سكيبي
مقابله مع احدى الصحف العالميه قالت ان
كان اي طرف يمكن ان يتحدث عن خطه لاستعاده
همم
بشكل همم
غير عسكري نرحب بذلك لكن طالما ان هذا ليس
ممكن سنواخر ما نقوم به الان
وهو تحرير اراضينا على يد جيشنا اما في
الولايات المتحده
وشركائنا الدوليين الاخرين
فانهم يحترمون سياده بلادنا
ويزودودوننا بالمساعدات العسكريه الرئيسيه
الا ان كل قرارات المتعلقه باراضينا
وخطتنا العسكريه
بها على الاطلاق
هل تستطيع اوكرانيا بنفسها ان تقوم بحمله
مثل هذه الحمله لاستعاده القرمه كما اعلنت
هذا من جهه ومن جهه اخرى الا تعتقدون ان
الامريكيين ربما في ظل
الدفع باتجاه حل سياسي وحل السلام في
اوكرانيا يعني قد يظنون ان مساله القرمه
قد تفتح الصراع على جبهات ونقاط اشتباك
جديده نقاط تماس وقواعد اشتراك جديده في
اوكرانيا وهذا ليس للمرحله التي يتوقعون
ان يتم فيها حال سياسي في المستقبل
اقول
[موسيقى]
بالمسائل لكن حسب ما نرى فان الولايات
المتحده لا تخطط للمشاركه عسكريه
لا يودون المشاركه في الاعمال الادائيه في
اوكرانيا
وبالنسبه لسؤالك الاول حول قدرات اوكرانيا
للقيام بمثل هذه العمليات العسكريه
حول هذا الوضع وكيف يتطور لكن نستطيع قوله
بناء
خبرتنا خلال الاشهر التسعه الاخيره هو ان
الجيش الاوكراني لديه دافع قوي
وحوافز وقادر على القيام
بعمليه عسكريه ذكيه راينا هذا
في خرسان
سنواصل
تنفيذ عملياتنا حتى ياتي ذلك الوقت عندما
نستعيد اراضينا بما فيها القربه
المفاجاه الاكبر في تاريخ كل كؤوس العالم
حدثت السعوديه بطلتها كيف الساعه بعد
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
على الارجنتين في كاس العالم مراكز التسوق
ولوحات الاعلانيه تهنئ الاخضر على الانجاز
واحده من كبرى مفاجاه كاس العالم عبر
التاريخ امرنا على العاهل السعوديه الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز يقرر اليوم التالي
للمباراه يوم اجازه بشكل رسمي ولماذا
الفوز تاريخي سنه
ساخنه كانت عنوان الاسبوع في الولايات
المتحده بل العالم هل اطلق
النار على قدمين
يتاهب الرجل لمرحله جديده اخرها كان
علامات توثيق بالوان مختلفه ذهبي رمادي
وازرق كلن حسب الجهه وكلها هذا يتم برفقه
مجموعه محدوده من الموظفين بعد زلزال
للاقالاته والاست هاتها فمن الذي يريد
ماسك ايصاله بالنسبه لمشتركي تويتر على
الامر واكثر سوداويه وتشائما اذا بدا وكان
منصات تنعى نفسها مبكرا وهذا ما جاء في
الوسم الذي انتشر مؤخرا رستم بيس تويتر او
ارقد بسلام تويتر هو ليس وصفا
فالخائفون على مصير تويتر يبحثون عن طرقا
لارشفه التغريدات تاريخ السته عشر عاما من
التغريد لكن هل الامر بهذا السوء يبدو ذلك
الثمد من يرى ان الى الماسك ان يتخبط ولا
يعرف ماذا يفعل غير ان ماسك رد ساخرا بهذه
الصوره
هلا ينهض ماسك فعلا بتويتر ثمات من يتوقع
غير ذلك فاستمرار العمل بشكل الطبيعي في
الشركه بات مستحيلا لا معايير في تسريح
الموظفين والاضطراب والارتباكوبتا
المسيطرين التوقعات متشائمه الاضطرابات
تعصف بالعصفور وثمت من يتوقع تكرار
الاغلاق في المكاتب العالميه لماذا مجزره
الاقالات والاستقالات هي السبب وحتى ترامب
لم يرى اي سببا يدفعه للعوده الى تويتر
رغم التصويت الذي الصباح في صالح عودته
وعيد تفعيل حساب الرئيس الامريكي السابق
لكن حديثه لم يخلو من اشاراته اشارات نقل
الاضطرابات الداخليه في تويتر مستقبل ده
ظبي اذا تمت من يرى ان سياسات سياسات
راسماليات تطل براسها ومخاوف على حريته
الراي والتعبير
احذروا تويتر قد يتوقف او ينهار المصير
الغامض اللي تويتر بعد موجه الايقالات
والاستقالات خاصه من المهندسين الذين
يشرفون على صيانته دفع الى هذا التحذير لا
سيما خلال كاس العالم بسبب العدد الهائلي
من الزوار الملك الجديد الين ماسك تحدى
المحذرين ودعى الى متابعه تويتر والسبب
تغطيه افضل للمونديال وذلك رغم الاعطال
الكثيره حول العالم قد تكون هذه الاعطال
بسبب مليون و600 الف مستخدم نشط يوميا
خلال الايام الماضيه رقم اعلنه مصر بنفسه
ووصفه بالاعلى على الاطلاق لكن ماذا عن
المستقبل ماسك بدا مرحله جديده من التوظيف
المهندسون وموظفون المبيعات لهم الاولويه
بينما وفي خطبه فسرها البعض بانها تراجع
وبعد ما صرحهم دعا ماسك مهندسين مستقيلين
الى العوده هل بسبب مطالبات التحقيق معه
ربما
مفاجاه السعوديه الاخيره امام الارجنتين
في كاس العالم وان كانت الابراج فهي ليست
الاولى في تاريخ المونديال سبقتها مفاجات
لكن ليست كثيره عاده المفاجات الا تحضر في
الحدث الكروي الابرز عالميا الا نادرا في
عام
1950 امريكا فاجات انجلترا بالفوز 1 - 0
انجلترا وصلت لمونديال البرازيل وهي واحده
من المرشحين لللقب وعرفت وقتها بمملكه كره
القدم لكن حضرت المفاجاه رغم ان مدرب
امريكا وقتها قال ليس لدينا فرصه ومن
انجلترا الى انجلترا لكن في عام
1960 الذي اقيم هناك لكن طرفي المفاجاه
كان مختلفين ايطاليا خسرت امام كوريا
الشماليه بهدف نظيف نحن الان في عام 1982
المونديال الذي اقيم في اسبانيا هذه مره
المفاجاه عربيه محاربوا الصحراء الجزائر
هزموا المانيا الغربيه بقائمتها النموذججه
بالنجوم بهدد بهدفين لهدف بعد ذلك ب 8
سنوات وفي مونديال ايطاليا 1990 كانت
الارجنتين ضحيه مفاجاه اخرى بطلها منتخب
الكاميرون الذي فاز على فريق مارادونا
بهدفا نظيف وفي عام 2002 مونديال كوريا
واليابان كانت دوله افريقيه اخرى هي بطله
المفاجاه لكن على حساب المنتخب الاوروبي
وليس امريكي جنوبيه السنغال وفي اول
مشاركه موندياليه لها حققت الفوز على بطله
العالم وقتها منتخب فرنسا
نعم هي اكبر مفاجاه في كاس العالم وليس
وصفا لتعظيم الانتصار وانما احصائيات
ودلائل من قبل شركه البيانات
[تصفيق]
هي الاقل عبر كل كؤوس العالم
8.7
السعوديه المصنفه 51 عالميا صنعت المستحيل
امام المصنف الثالث والمرشح لقب المونديال
الارجنتين
تقدمت الارجنتين بهدف للنجم الابرز طبعا
ليونيل ميسي في الدقيقه العاشره عن طريق
ركله جزاء وهنا ضمن الجميع ان النتيجه
ستكون كبيره على الاخضر لكن النتيجه
استمرت هكذا حتى جاء الشوط الثاني لم
ينتظر السعوديون كثيرا التعادل في الدقيقه
الثامنه والاربعين باقدام صالح الشهري اول
اهداف السعوديه على الاطلاق في كاس العالم
ضد فريق سبق له حمل لقب
خمسه ودقائق اخرى كانت كفيله من اجل الهدف
الثاني سالم الدوسري وبمهاره كبيره يسكن
الكرات في شباك الارجنتين لتتحقق المفاجاه
لكن كيف حدثت
المدير الفرنسي للمنتخب السعودي هو السبب
الابرز كما نشاهد نسبه امتلاك الكره كانت
للارجنتين كانت 69% مقابل 31 للسعوديه
امرنا منطقي وطبيعي بالنظر لامكانات
الفريقين لكن حيله خطيره لاعبه عليها
لنهار وطبقت بشكل رائع من قبل لاعبيه
مصيده التسلل التي كانت سببا من اسباب
الفوز وقعت الارجنتين في التسلل 10 مرات
منها ثلاث مرات احرزت فيها اهدافا والغيا
مقابله مره واحده على السعوديه
[موسيقى]
هذا بالطبع بجانبي بسالتي لاعبي المنتخب
السعوديه التي منحت العرب انتصارا هو
الابرز مشاهدينا في كؤوس العالم
وصلنا الى نهايه
تابعونا غدا الحزام الذهبي هدف ايراني في
العراق
فسادنا وخطه اجتياح بري وفي لبنان
في وقت واسجد حربا اهليه في اخر المونديال
الوجوه الاخرى سياسيه طبعا
في نهايه الساعه ابرز واحداث الساعه بصور
من الان واحد تسعه المقبله انا حنين
الشولي وهذه الساعه 6:00
[موسيقى]